Hey Youtubers happy 2017!
There's so much new awesome stuff dropping
this year between movies and TV shows this
is going to be a video to let you know about
what's going on most of the stuff I already
do regular videos for but if you're new to
the channel.
I do weekly giveaways.
So be sure to click that bell to enable alerts
so you don't miss anything.
So much stuff to hype.
So let's start with the really big comic book
movies so the first big comic book movie of
the year is actually Lego Batman.
I don't know if you consider that a comic
book movie or not that that's dropping February
10 I'll probably do like a review video for
that on I'm not planning on making a ton of
Lego Batman content.
As you can imagine the first big superhero
movie is gonna be Logan the new Wolverine
movie drops March 3, so that is you coming
up pretty quickly and as guardians of the
galaxy to May 5 then wonder woman is June
2 in Spider-Man homecoming is Fourth of July
weekend in Thor Ragnarok is like right after
that at the end of July like July 28 then
Justice league is November 17 and of course
Star Wars episode eight.
The thing we been waiting for for so long
now is December 15.
So if Marvel and DC own the summer for the
rest of time than Star Wars owns Christmas
in December for the rest of time.
In fact, they just reschedule the Han Solo
movie from spring 2018 to that December weekend
that they always release all their movies
so new Star Wars every year in December for
the rest of time which just sounds like the
best thing ever like all the creative that
they released for all these movies so far,
especially like Logan, which is like a really
small movie in stark contrast to the previous
Wolverine movies in the other X-Men franchise
movies just looks amazing.
Like probably the best treatment of that character
in a movie.
Given the context of this is is like very
old man Logan.
So when we get closer to that movie if you
haven't read the old man Logan story.
I'll explain that I'll be doing a bunch of
Logan stuff the be bunch, Wolverine videos
because they're supposed to be like a funny
Deadpool end tag seen it doesn't have anything
to do with the Logan movie, but because Deadpool
is so huge right now Fox wants to remind you
that Deadpool is the thing that they make
movies for that.
We might not see till 2018.
But like they just want to keep fans happy
because there's no new Deadpool this year
on the DC side of things.
Wonder woman is also like a huge creative
shift from behind-the-scenes because it's
the beginning of the Geoff John's era of DC
films.
So whatever misgivings you may have had about
other DC movies I feel like wonder woman will
be like the shift back in the right direction
that is been a lot of talk about the other
new films like Aqua man for the Batman movie.
I just did a video about that.
So at a link at the end of this the just trying
to focus on the stuff that's happening this
year we can talk about like, way further off
Marvel and DC stuff in another video, so on
the TV side of things.
There are like a lot of returning shows lot
of comic book stuff is coming back in January
but there's also a bunch of new stuff you've
never seen before like the brand-new X-Men
show this dropping.
The Legion is on FX.
So it's not on network am super excited about
that it's on the FX network, so it's cable.
So I'm hoping that is just like super graphics
super weird.
And they can do all the things you can't do
on network shows like agents of shield, but
that's based on the Legion character from
Marvel comics, who is sort of like the non-cannon
son of Prof. X that has many many multiple
personalities, each with his own superpower.
So like you see in the trailer he's this super
mutant to get stuck in an institution and
they weave in a lot of the X-Men lore why
haven't seen the first episode yet but it
seems like it's gonna be really good.
It's a Wednesday night show.
It starts February 8.
So it still couple weeks away all due like
a Legion trailer video just remind everyone
like a lot of the stuff on talking about here
I already do videos for so from throwing like
a whole bunch of stuff, at you guys in this
video all remind you of the other stuff whenever
I post videos for each of these things speaking
of Marvel though we have all the marvel Netflix
stuff is dropping and it's all brand-new series
that you've never seen before iron fist drops
March 17 is a much the same weekend the daredevil
season two drop defenders is after that they
have not confirmed when they're dropping it.
It could either come during the summer.
It could come later in the year.
Like around the time Luke Cage dropped in
September, but the punisher is the other thing
that they're working on, and it looks like
they might finish it in time to drop it during
December.
So a production can stay on track.
We might get three new Marvel Netflix series
this year.
Now they are working on season two of Jessica
Jones.
The other serious like there will be a daredevil
season three.
But we can talk more about that when I post
more Netflix videos.
A lot of you asked about agents of shield
that I haven't done a video in a little while
that's coming back next week, in their actually
shifting the focus of the show room ghostwriter
to life model decoys and ETA.
So for better or worse, like the focus of
the show is going to be changing fundamentally,
but that doesn't mean that ghostwriter won't
be a part of the show anymore, so all due
like a trailer video for agents of shield
little talk a little bit more about that life
model decoys is going to consume the big back
half of the season all of the DC TV shows
on the CW come back in about three weeks legends
of tomorrow is a schedule change now.
That's going to be after the flash on Tuesday
night so they'll be some more trailer videos
for all that stuff so I'll explain the schedule
change when I post those legends of tomorrow
is on Tuesdays.
Now, instead of Thursdays that kinda means
that the video schedule is gonna change a
little bit during the week a couple things
are going to get shuffled around, but will
figured out all explained when I post those
videos of the big DC comic book stuff that
was confirmed.
The Geoff John's new TV show made it sound
like that was gonna drop later this year so
that might not be till like way at the end
of the year will wait to hear more about that
once we do all do a new video about it but
you young justice season three is in production
there figuring it out but because it takes
so long to animate I don't think it's gonna
drop till 2018.
But it'll probably be sometime early 2018.
So other big stuff.
Rick and Morty everyone's freaking out about
where season three when the gonna drop why
they radio silent the best rumor right now
is that it's gonna drop sometime in March
it's a Sunday night adult swim show on Cartoon
Network, so if you haven't seen.
I started doing videos for Rick and Morty
just to get everybody ready I'll be doing
episode videos when it gets here.
So it's actually crazy all of the episodes
are on Hulu right now if you're in the UK
or somewhere else in the world is probably
on Netflix for you American gods another big
huge genre adaptation based on Neil Gaiman's
book he's planning on writing more that to
the first season will only cover like the
first part of the book, it's supposed to drop
sometime early 2017 that could be March that
could be April, but it's gonna be on stars
inside the United States and then everywhere
else it's gonna be on Amazon, so I'll deafly
be doing videos for all that I'm really excited
is one of my favorite books.
American gods is great.
If you have the time definitely check it out
or listen to the audiobook it's a great story
and then if you haven't seen it during Christmas.
There was this new Guillermo Del Toro show
called troll hunters that dropped this kind
of aimed at younger kids but it's actually
pretty fantastic.
The way they weave the mythology.
Kelsey grammar plays a character Tom Hiddleston
even plays a characters they have like this
a list cast all the episodes run Netflix is
just part one.
So there animating season two right now.
So there will be a troll hunters season too
later this year but it's like my new comfort
food right now during the holidays like I've
already watched it through twice the episodes
are little bit shorter though if your big
fan of old Tron the dropping Voltron season
two on Netflix in about two weeks that's being
done by the same team that the legend of Cora,
so that sort of like the early part of the
year and like the other like really big stuff
the signpost that are coming later in the
year.
So if it all feels like almost too much to
hold in your head right now.
Don't worry.
I'll be doing individual bonus videos for
all the stuff like of course I do DC TV.
I do Marvel videos.
So I'll remind people when stuff is dropping
when it's getting ready to come.
So just wanted to do this video just remind
everybody about like a really awesome stuff
that's coming all the creative looks fantastic
from all the movie people at all the different
studios I am really excited about the Logan
movie because it is the rated R, Wolverine
movie that you been asking for like the last
10 years is going to be so awesome but there's
like a TV show or a movie that I forgot to
put on this list that you guys are really
excited about just include in the comments,
I know you people wondering about game of
thrones two that's coming sometime later in
the summer I'm guessing like end of June early
July will be seven episodes.
Don't worry.
It just that they haven't confirmed anything
about when is dropping or what's going on
with that HBO is been radio silent for a while.
So there will be some new Game of thrones
coming relatively soon but I want to focus
on the more definite stuff for this video,
so everybody get height when he 17 is going
to be so awesome.
I know a lot of you are asking about them
confirming Dr. strange in Thor Ragnarok.
That will be my next video, so that will post
Tuesday morning while you guys wait for that
to post you can click here to learn why everyone's
freaking out about the Batman movie and you
can click here to learn about that new DC
TV show thank you so much watching 2017 can
be awesome.
I'll see you guys tonight!